ich begrüße sie herzlich wieder zum
pressebriefing robert-koch-institutes
dienstag der fünfte mai 2020 heute
wieder mit professor lothar wieler
präsident des robert koch instituts wie
üblich gibt es erst ein statement und
danach die möglichkeit für die
medienvertreter fragen zu stellen er
weder bitte guten morgen meine damen und
herren zunächst das wichtigste zu den
zahlen in kürze die entwicklung der
fallzahlen in den letzten tagen wurden
nur um die 700 bis 1600 neue fälle pro
tag ans robert koch institut übermittelt
das heißt die zahl der übermittelten
infektionsfälle ist sinkt weiter das ist
eine sehr gute nachricht
die produktionszahl liegt heute
geschätzt war etwa 0,71 die anzahl der
neu übermittelten todesfälle ist
weiterhin hoch
in den letzten tagen wurden immer noch
circa 40 bis 200 neue todesfälle pro tag
übermittelt und hier sind die
schwankungen natürlich besonders groß an
den feiertagen und wochenenden
es gibt einen kontinuierlichen anstieg
des verstorbenen anteils in den letzten
wochen auf aktuell damit 4,2 prozent und
weiterhin wird von ausbrüchen alters und
pflegeheim berichtet sowie auch in
krankenhäusern und in einigen dieser
ausbrüche ich die zahl der verstorbenen
vergleichsweise hoch es werden weiterhin
anstrengungen unternommen um die test
kapazitäten weiter zu erhöhen
das ist sehr wichtig um ein genaueres
bild von der situation in deutschland zu
bekommen
und ich kann sagen dass seit beginn der
testungen in deutschland bis
einschließlich der der woche 17
dieses jahres bisher rund 2,4 millionen
labortests erfasst wurden
und davon wurden ca 7,2 prozent positiv
auf saas kauf 2 getestet
gemäss der abfrage des robert koch
instituts und einem labor verbund liegen
die tests kapazitäten in der woche 18 in
der kalenderwoche 18
bei rund 142.000 pro tag
das sind die daten von insgesamt 100
33 laboren weiterhin dass wir zudem auch
ausreichende behandlungskapazitäten
vorhalten können in deutschland
insbesondere ausreichend intensivbetten
und beatmungsgeräte alle kliniken mit
intensivbetten im die wie intensiv
register erfasst werden auch das ist ein
wichtiger erfolg der unsere
möglichkeiten der einwirkt der befassung
mit den kapazitäten sehr sehr gut
eröffnet und bei der derzeitigen dynamik
muss man deutlich sagen werden keine
engpässe prognostiziert voraussetzung
dafür ist natürlich dass die anzahl an
neuen erkrankungsfällen nicht wieder
ansteigt die darf nicht wieder ansteigen
dafür werden wir weiter sorge tragen
kurz zu einem internationalen vergleich
situation in deutschland und weltweit
deutschland hat ist der stand von 50 50
uhr und die anderen länder wie immer vom
einen tag früher für vierter 15 uhr die
zahlen die ich ihn vorlese sind alles
gerundete zahlen vereinigte staaten
haben zu diesem zeitpunkt rund 1,15 1
1.000.000 158.000 fälle darunter
befinden sich 77 67 1700 todesfälle
das heißt der anteil der todesfälle pro
100.000 einwohner in den usa ist damit
bei 20,8 spanien ein europäischer
nachbar 217 1500 fälle und insgesamt
25.000 300 todesfälle
dort liegen die todesfälle pro 100000
einwohner bei 54 und zwei schauen wir
das vereinigte königreich an mit 186
1600 fällen insgesamt 28.400 todesfälle
hier haben wir 43,1 todesfälle pro
100.000 einwohner und wenn wir uns dann
deutschland anschauen
aktuelle zahlen rund 163.000 900 dann
haben wir hier in deutschland rund 6800
todesfälle bislang vermeldet dann sind
das in deutschland pro 100.000 einwohner
8,2 todesfälle
mittlerweile sind weltweit rund 3,4
millionen fälle bekanntgeworden nahezu
alle länder sind betroffen
ausbruchsgeschehen stark in nordamerika
und europa und ich verweise wie immer
darauf dass die akt ausführlichen
fallzahlen auf den seiten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und spd zu
finden sind und diese zeiten sind ja
auch auf unser chor wird 19 seite
verlinkt kommen wir nun zur
epidemiologischen situation in
deutschland
in deutschland wurden heute bis 50
fünfter standen null uhr exakt 163
1860-coach fälle übermittelt das sind
685 mehr als am vortag
und darunter waren bislang insgesamt
6800 31 todesfälle
das sind rund 139 mehr als am vortag
dh die gesamt incidents in deutschland
beträgt 100 97 fälle pro 100.000
einwohner
die gesamt incidents variiert
deutschlandweit weiterhin bayern sind es
zurzeit 330 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
und in mecklenburg vorpommern 44 fälle
pro 100.000 einwohner
wie ich schon sagte wurden in den
letzten wochen circa 700 bis 1600 fälle
pro tag übermittelt und die zahl der
genesene schätzen wir auf 135.000 100
wie immer können sie die fallzahlen die
zahl der chinesen täglich aktualisiert
auf dem dashboard abrufen dass sie unter
krone.at punkt de einsehen können
dort geben wir detaillierte information
die jedem immer zur verfügung stehen
und ich möchte auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass wir auch umfangreich
dokumentiert jeden tag einen neuen
situationsbericht ins internet stellen
mit einer lage-einschätzung und den
finden sie auf www.ard.de / co witt - 19
diesen bericht stellen wir immer am
nachmittag oder späten nachmittag 1
und er umfasst unter anderem
kartenmaterial das sehr schön
illustriert wie die situation in
deutschland aussieht aktuell ein paar
informationen zu den fällen wie sind sie
klinisch präsentiert männer und frauen
sind etwa gleichermaßen betroffen
durchschnittsalter liegt bei rund 50
jahren und bei vier von fünf der
übermittelten fälle das sind insgesamt
134000 da liegen uns klinische
informationen vor husten haben etwa
jeder zweite 50 prozent fieber und 41
prozent also vier von zehn und schnupfen
etwa zwei von zehn
wir haben auch den geschmacks und
geruchs verlust aufgenommen
und hier sehen wir zurzeit dass das bei
16 prozent erfasst wurde von den
entsprechenden ämtern
wir wissen weiterhin das rund 18 prozent
also fast jeder fünfte der fälle ins
krankenhaus aufgenommen werden musste
doch behandelt wird das entspricht rund
23.300 fällen von den 133 1000 fällen wo
und diese information vorliegt und wir
wissen dass rund 2,8 prozent der
offiziell gemeldeten fälle das sind rund
3700 wir wissen dass diese personen eine
lungenentzündung entwickelt haben
die todesfälle
ich sagte dass es bislang 6831 fälle
sind die offiziell an das robert koch
institut in zusammenhang mit komik 19
erkrankung verstorben gemeldet wurden
das sind nun 4,2 prozent
das heißt dieser anteil ist weiterhin
hoch
und das liegt sicher auch daran dass wir
immer noch ausbrüche in alters- und
pflegeheim und auch in krankenhäusern
sehen wo ja besonders die risikogruppen
betroffen sind die eine größere chance
haben schwer zu erkranken oder eben auch
zu versterben
wir sehen generell weiterhin viele
erkrankungsfälle bei älteren menschen
und die todesfälle die jetzt ja gemeldet
werden betreffen die menschen die ihm
vor längerer zeit ein zwei vielleicht
auch vor drei wochen erkrankt sind oder
infiziert wurden und wir wissen auch
dass immer noch weitere kurve 19 fälle
in stationärer behandlung sind und das
heißt wir müssen also davon ausgehen
dass es auch weitere todesfälle geben
wird die menschen in deutschland die
verstorben sind im rahmen von kogit 19
waren im durchschnitt 81 jahre alt und
87 prozent der verstorbenen person sind
über 70 jahre alt und älter
ich möchte noch kurz zum abschluss etwas
zur arbeitsweise des
robert-koch-instituts sagen worauf ich
in den letzten wochen abo zu hingewiesen
habe aber heute noch mal ein wenig
kondensiert wie wir zu unseren
einschätzungen kommen zu unseren
empfehlungen kommen wir sind ja
wissenschaftler und aktuell liegt
natürlich der fokus auf den
infektionsschutz
das heißt im schutz vor cupid 19 wir
sammeln sowie viele andere forscher
weltweit fieberhaft daten werden sie
ausstellen hypothesen auf prüfen diese
hypothesen vorwerfen sie oder bestätigen
sie unsere kenntnisse wachsen aktuell in
einem rasanten tempo wenn man weiß dass
diese krankheit der erst seit wenigen
monaten überhaupt bekannt ist
unser ziel ist es die bevölkerung
deutschland von kogit 19 bestmöglich zu
schützen und das ist uns in deutschland
bislang verglichen mit vielen anderen
ländern sehr gut gelungen wie sie das
auch an den zahlen sehen die ich gerade
eben wieder vorgestellt habe es ist die
aufgabe des robert koch instituts aus
den erkenntnissen die wir gewinnen und
die wir auch aus erkenntnisse von
anderen studien gewinn
dass wir daraus empfehlungen erstellen
daran arbeiten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus sehr vielen
verschiedenen fachlichen bereichen am
robert koch institut arbeiten mediziner
medizinerinnen epidemiologen
biophysikerin mathematikerinnen und
viele andere berufsgruppen mehr
und natürlich stehen wir alle ständig im
fachlichen austausch mit
forschungsinstituten universitäten
behörden und zwar nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in vielen
anderen ländern der welt
ich hatte ihnen ja vor einiger zeit eine
lange liste mit aktivitäten vorgestellt
wie wir dabei vorgehen und welche
projekte es gibt und auch unsere liste
an wissenschaftlichen publikationen
wächst kontinuierlich das alles finden
sie auf der website des robert koch
instituts rki de / kogit - 19 und dort
unter der rubrik forschung und wir
informieren transparent wir tun alles um
ein möglichst klares bild der situation
zu gewinnen und zwar ist es unser ziel
dass evidenzbasiert zu gewinnen also auf
der basis wissenschaftlich überprüfbare
fakten und warum tun wir das weil wir
der politik dabei helfen wollen mit
unseren daten entscheidungen zu treffen
aber um das noch mal deutlich zu sagen
wir schätzen die aktuelle situation auf
der basis von wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen ein
und das kann immer nur eine
momentaufnahme sein
da kann es auch sein dass sich
einschätzung ändern
wir befinden uns in einem laufenden
prozess einem dynamischen prozess nach
wie vor und dieser dynamische prozess
läuft auf vielen ebenen danke vielen
dank wir kommen zu den fragen und fangen
mit n tv an herr akw lag leicht anderen
das was sie gesagt haben zum thema wo
finden eigentlich neuinfektionen statt
können sie das ein bisschen
quantifizieren wenn sie sagen ihn
einrichten und altersheimen
krankenhäusern altersheimen da gibt es
immer noch ein deutliches aufkommen von
neuinfektionen gibt es das aber auch in
der restlichen bevölkerung also sie und
ich könnten wir uns auch anstecken oder
stecken
ja das ist eine gute frage die wir gerne
beantworten würden können aber leider
gibt es gründe warum wir das nicht in
dem maße beantworten können wir das
gerne wird also erstens mal nach den
erkenntnissen die uns vorliegen sind
etwa ein drittel der fälle die uns
bekannt sind die aus diesen
einrichtungen oder im zusammenhang mit
diesen einrichtungen stehen das heißt
aber auch auf der anderen seite dass ihm
zwei drittel wir nicht gut zuordnen
können und das ist bedauerlich
das liegt daran dass die meldedaten das
zum einen nicht in der detailtiefe
hergeben
und das liegt zum anderen auch daran
dass wir durch die gesundheitsämter die
ja nach wie vor sehr stark involviert
sind und den ausbruch von kämpfen dass
die gesundheitsämter eben nach wie vor
dabei sind diese ausbrüche zu bekämpfen
und noch nicht dazu gekommen sind
viele dieser ausbrüche auch adäquat zu
dokumentieren und zu publizieren
das geschieht ja immer wieder
insbesondere in unserem epidemiologische
butter wir gehen auch davon aus dass das
zukünftig wieder mehr der fall sein wird
aber momentan ist das aus zeitlichen
gründen noch nicht genügend gelungen
kurze nachfrage noch zu den neuen
funktionen gibt es denn sonst szenario
weil wir aber mal die schwelle von
10.000 aktiv infizierten unterscheiden
oder auch eine modellrechnung
modellierung war der erste tag in
deutschland sein keine neuen infektionen
haben tut mir leid damit kann ich ihnen
nicht dienen
ich denke der entscheidende punkt ist
der wir haben uns ja einen großartigen
erfolg zusammen erkämpft das muss man so
sagen und wenn wir den gut verteidigen
dann werden die zahlen niedrig bleiben
und das muss das ziel sein das heißt
also wir sollten immer wachsam sein und
immer die abstandsregel einhalten also
abstand halten sicher der neue alltag
und der wird dann dazu beitragen dass
infektionszahlen niedrig bleiben wir
gehen zum südwestrundfunk herr kammerer
30 prozent ermittelt bei 1000 franken
person ist er wieder irgendwie weil sie
ist in dieser rate auch auf deutschland
übertragbar ja das ist eine sehr gute
frage
also zunächst mal ist das eine wichtige
richtige studie auf deren ergebnisse
viele lange gewartet und nicht lange
stimmt gar nichts das ist wirklich sehr
sehr schnell provoziert worden aber
gewartet haben das ist eine rate die für
ein bestimmtes gebiet gilt das ist eine
valide studie man sieht das an den daten
publiziert sind an den methoden die
verwendet wurden und man darf das
natürlich nicht auf oder sagen wir mal
man kann das schwerlich auf ganz
deutschland übertragen weil es dort eine
bestimmten ausbruch gab der
mitbestimmten hintergründen untersucht
wurde es hängt immer noch davon ab wie
viel personen denn wirklich getestet
wurden das ist eine repräsentative
studie
zunächst mal ist es eine gute nachricht
wenn die die todesrate die letalität
rate in diesem ort 0.37 ist für alle
wünschen uns ja dass die todes heute
möglichst niedrig ist nachfrage dazu
daten von den strecken ja auch immer
wieder mal in der kritik jetzt auch
gerade dem fall ist die zahl der ohne
daten von knapp 1000 personen
überschaubar würden sie sagen dass die
daten auch jetzt gesagt vielleicht
vorsicht zu genießen sind die da erhoben
wurden
nein hier gibt es glaube ich in der in
der öffentlichkeit ein missverständnis
also diese daten sind mit einer sauberen
nachvollziehbaren studiendesign und mit
adäquaten methoden erhoben worden
aber es sind eben daten die für diesen
bestimmten ort für diesen kreis bzw für
diesen ort gangelt gelten und wo ich
manchmal das gefühl habe dass
personendaten die in einem bestimmten
setting erhoben werden mit bestimmten
methoden mit bestimmten einschränkungen
und bestimmt aussage kräften dass die
einfach von manchen personen auf ein
ganzes land übertragen werden das ist
die problematik die studie ist ist eine
ausgezeichnete wissenschaftliche studie
aber die interpretation der studie durch
manche menschen das ist glaube ich
das fraglich und wenn sie die studie
lesen auch die diskussion lesen dann ist
das eben adäquat diskutiert wenn
menschen daraus schlüsse ziehen
die man daraus nicht ziehen sollte dann
ist das definitiv nicht das versäumnis
der wissenschaftler die eine publikation
darüber verfassen in der sie möglichst
viele einblicke in die methodik und den
studios studiendesign geben
wir gehen zum zdf morgenmagazin jacobs
guten morgen herr wieder noch mal eine
frage zum europäischen vergleich
wenn wir auch die kombi aus ganz europa
blicken da ist ja grob gesagt im
zeitfenster in dieser pandemie ähnlich
weitgehend ähnlich agiert worden und wir
haben jetzt auch weitgehend vergleichbar
ähnliche entwicklungen rückgang der
fallzahlen
wenn wir mal so als ein extrem den
spanien wo besonders drastische
maßnahmen betroffen waren sie seit mitte
märz schon drastische ausgangssperre
geschäftsschließungen da ist jetzt für
mich noch die frage nach sechs oder
sieben wochen warum gibt es denn da
überhaupt noch mehr als 1000 fälle neue
täglich müsste das nicht mehr zu null
sein wie erklären sie sich dass und wenn
ich als anderes extrem schweden immer
noch da ist die entwicklung einigermaßen
positiv er kleine 1 die bio sieht das
positiv heißt das nicht in gewisser
weise dass abgesehen von den maßnahmen
die alle getroffen haben europaweit also
da denke ich vor allen dingen an die
absage von großveranstaltungen das
unterbinden von menschenansammlungen in
großen rollen von hunderten oder
tausenden dass die maßnahmen die also
darüber hinaus gehen
im europäischen vergleich nicht so die
großen signifikanten unterschiede
gebracht haben und das zugespitzt gesagt
vielleicht besonders drastische
maßnahmen nur wenig mehr gemacht haben
kann ich empfehle ich nicht so
detailliert beantworten also was sicher
ist was stimmt ist dass die verläufe
relativ ähnlich sind wenn es um
zeiträume geht wenn sie die anfang
anfänge der testungen sehen dann sehen
sie hier die zeiträume relativ ähnlich
was sicher ein großer unterschied ist
aber dass zwar bei manchen die zeiträume
ähnlich sind aber der das geschehen
schon deutlich weiter fortgeschritten
waren neben wir jetzt italien zum
beispiel
dort hat man erst diese epidemie etwas
später kann
und dann hat man zunächst viele
todesfälle gehabt und an den todesfällen
erkannt dass ich in kurve 9 10 handel
bei uns in deutschland haben wir sehr
früh erkannt
durch gute testungen und durch eine
aufmerksamkeit im gesundheitssystem
die maßnahmen sind ziemlich vergleichbar
es ist wirklich nicht möglich dass man
jetzt einzelnen maßnahmen bestimmte
effekte zubilligt klar ist aber da kenne
ich mich natürlich am besten jetzt auch
in deutschland weil die anderen staaten
teilweise doch ein bisschen
diversifizierte maßnahmen getroffen
haben spanien zum beispiel hat am anfang
wenn ich mich recht erinnere in
besonderen risikogebieten besonders
drastische maßnahmen gefahren und in
anderen gebieten lockere maßnahmen
gehalten werden das in deutschland ja
direkt deutschlandweit durchgeführt
werden sofern kann man das auch schlecht
vergleichen so so gehe ich davon aus
dass dieses bündel der maßnahmen der
erfolg war wenn sie in deutschland auf
die kurve schauen sei es nun die reine
meldete das heißt die neue casting kurve
dann sehen sie das immer in zeitlichen
abstand von etwa drei wochen nach der
jeweiligen maßnahme immer noch mal ein
bestimmter niedrig oder niedergang der
der zahlen zu sehen war
die einzelnen maßnahmen was sie denn
genau bewirkten ist schwer zu sagen klar
ist natürlich auch das frühe maßnahmen
und besonders guten effekt haben und
dann wenn man spätere maßnahmen für das
deren effekt auf die gesamtzahl immer
etwas geringer ist wird natürlich der
größte effekt es am anfang am ende so
eine epidemie oder diese erste welle
wirklich runterzubringen dauert
natürlich lange und erfordert sehr viel
durch ein programm
aber vielleicht die kleine nachfrage
noch wieso hat spanien überhaupt noch
mehr als 1000 fälle aus hessen
naja also offensichtlich gibt es dort
eben ein krankheitsgeschehen dass sie
stärker ausbreitet ich ich kann nicht
genau beurteilen wie die menschen dass
in einzelnen settings umsätzen ich weiß
zum beispiel dass die deutschen und auch
die schwedin übrigens wo die maßnahmen
von aus betrachtet ja gar nicht so
drastisch waren die schweden selber
haben sich sehr stark daran gehalten
sind zu hause geblieben von alleine
haben ab statt
gehalten und die deutschen haben das
auch sehr diszipliniert gemacht das ist
ja der grund warum wir heute so relativ
entspannt sein können wie das in spanien
ist das kann ich ihn tatsächlich nicht
beantworten
wir gehen zum ende wieder her
ich habe vor ihren vom hintergrund ihrer
ausführungen zu evidenzbasierten
ratschlägen weil eine frage zum thema
reisebeschränkungen und
grenzschließungen die bhu redner klar
doch schon ab grenzen zu schliessen und
reisebeschränkungen zu machen weil sie
sagen dafür gibt es keinen nutzen
nachbar ist allenfalls aber ist in der
frühen phase der epidemien den ersten
zwei bis drei wochen könnte es etwas
verzögern so zu sagen dass das geschehen
jetzt ist die frage vor dem hintergrund
haben sieht und installierung dem
innenministerium zu grenzschließungen
und reisebeschränkungen geraten oder
abgeraten
nun wir beraten ja nicht das
innenministerium also die diese
entscheidungen über grenzschließungen
sind politische entscheidungen die
getroffen werden im rahmen von
bestimmten zusammenhängen und das ist
ein gebiet das nicht unseres betrifft
dann den wir zuvor story von der leyen
frau hören
ich spreche mal ganz laut geht das so
ich wollte fragen weil gestern bekannt
wurde dass ein neuer antikörper test von
roche die zulassung bekommen hat und
dass der 43 millionen dieser antikörper
thies nach deutschland geliefert werden
sollen
es ist ja die möglichkeit dass man sich
auch privat so ein antikörpertest dann
besorgt wie sieht das beurteilen wie sie
das einschätzen auch vor dem hintergrund
ist wahrscheinlich die durchseuchung in
deutschland noch relativ gering ist und
vielleicht noch mal ein wort zu dem
immunitätsausschuss wie sie die
gesellschaftlichen folgen einschätzen
er ist so ein passgeber ja also zunächst
zudem antikörpertest die informationen
die mir über den test vorliegen besagen
dass der test eine ganz gute test
qualitätsparameter hat die reden wir uns
interessiert da vor allen dingen die so
genannte spezifität und die sensitivität
die spezifität heißt von wirklich
antikörper tragenden personen wie viel
davon wenden da als richtig entdeckt und
das liegt beides meines wissens diese
diese zahlen liegen beide über 99
prozent
was ich weiter über den test weiß ist
dass er nicht unterscheidet zwischen
verschiedenen immunglobulin klassen und
interessierte gm das ist in der regel
die erste immunglobulin klasse dass
antikörper em kommt als erstes sehr früh
im infektionsverlauf und dann gibt es eg
das ist ein antikörper der vor allen
dingen system ist eine rolle spielt
entschuldigung und dann gibt es eba eba
spielt vor allen dingen lokal eine rolle
und dieser antikörper test weist meiner
kenntnis nach alle diese drei nach das
ist einerseits gut das ist ein grund
warum die die sensitivität so hoch ist
und die spezifität auf der anderen seite
aber erschwert es dadurch zu sagen ob
die immunantwort und die antikörper
antwort früh oder spät verlief und auf
der anderen seite
ist meines kenntnisstand auch wird ein
bestimmtes protein das virus
nachgewiesen dass sogenannte nude-look
absieht protein das ist ein protein das
offensichtlich gut erkannt wird aber
nach unserem heutigen kenntnisstand muss
es nicht so sein dass antikörper gegen
dieses protein nur hohe assoziation zu
einer immunität haben dass das ist
momentan nach dem stand der wissenschaft
auf einfach nicht klar
die immunität ausweise sind prinzipiell
zu überlegen aber wir müssen eben
wirklich marke haben das heißt wir
müssen wirklich wissen wann eine person
immun ist und momentan gibt es weltweit
noch nicht genügend informationen
darüber zu sagen welche parameter wir
bei patienten messen um sagen zu können
dass sie immun sind das sind laufen
untersuchungen
und wir alle hoffen natürlich dass wir
das in kürze wirklich sagen können
momentan ist das leider nicht möglich
morgen der große gipfel der
bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten es geht
schwerpunktmäßig um die lockerung der
aktuell geltenden maßnahmen die für
dieses gespräch der kanzlerin wo kann
man lockern und wo sollte man es auf
jeden fall noch nicht also meine
empfehlungen die an das ministerium für
gesundheit gehen gehen eher darauf
welche maßnahmen man und welche
indikatoren welche welche messparameter
man nehmen muss ja und das ist der
entscheidende punkt wie die dann
umgesetzt werden ist eine entscheidung
die er nicht in unserer hand liegt und
die auch lokal natürlich getroffen
werden muss weil die verhältnisse eben
in verschiedenen regionen des landes
unterschiedlich sind
aber was sind die die messparameter die
uns interessieren also die indikatoren
wir müssen da jetzt wollen wir das
das geschehen halbwegs unter kontrolle
haben wenn sie auf die landkarten
schauen dann sehen sie es gibt zurzeit
gerade noch zwei landkreise in
deutschland wo die inzidenz über 50
100.000 liegt das ist traunstein und
greiz
also wir haben wirklich sehr erfolgreich
bislang diese erste welle der epidemie
bekämpft was sind die parameter die
jetzt betrachtet werden müssen und man
muss dann quasi sagen wenn diese
parameter signale geben dann muss man
wieder die lockerungen zurücknehmen und
zwar lokal das ist zum einen die
übertragbarkeit wir nennen das
transmission bei der übertragbarkeit ist
dieser faktor einer der eine rolle
spielt aber es ist natürlich die
gesamtzahl der nachgewiesenen fälle
spielt eine große rolle und die dynamik
der inzidenz also der der häufigkeit von
fällen in einer bestimmten region
das zweite was uns interessiert ist die
krankheit schwerer
das heißt also wie stark sind die
personen krank und da haben wir zwischen
ganz gute hinweise wissen ja dass rund
18% hospitalisiert werden müssen also
ins krankenhaus in im krankenhaus
behandelt werden müssen
wir wissen den prozent zahl derjenigen
die eine lungenentzündung entwickeln
das müssen wir im auge halten und das
dritte dann was eine rolle spielt ist
die kapazität kapazität im
gesundheitssystem und hier spielen die
zwei kapazitäten rollen eben nicht nur
die versorgung das ist wichtig die in
verden natürlich die intensivbetten die
beatmung spread sie haben wir dieses
hervorragende diese register in
deutschland angeschafft das uns daran
tollen einblick gibt das ist wirklich
weltweit fast ein unikat das ist
großartig und hier ist natürlich auch
wichtig die kapazität der lokalen
gesundheitsbehörden und das heißt also
wie viele ausbrüche können sie dennoch
managen sind sie in der lage zu brechen
wir müssen schnell erkennen sie müssen
schnell ausbrüchen können und dazu
gehört auch die kapazität der testungen
wie viele tests stehen zur verfügung um
schnell sensitivität zu testen und das
heißt also diese drei gruppen von
parametern die sind die die empfohlen
werden und wie dann vor ort mit welchen
parametern welche entscheidung getroffen
werden ist wirklich eine entscheidung
die die player vor ort stellen treffen
müssen weil sie wissen was sie noch
regeln können oder wo sie unterstützung
brauchen klarheit hat schon im
alleingang gelockert als kleiner erlaubt
das zusammenkommen dürfen wieder wachsen
mit einer teileröffnung der gastronomie
ab
kommenden montag wie bewerten sie diese
beiden fälle was könnte dann im
schlimmsten fall passieren könnten die
infektion wieder rasant ansteigt
naja ich wie gesagt kann die
begebenheiten vor ort kann ich von hier
aus nicht betrachten
es ist ja prinzipiell so wenn wir
lockern steigt natürlich die chance dass
es wieder infektionen gibt und das ist
ja der grund warum wir in den letzten
wochen die zeit dafür genutzt haben die
kapazitäten zu verbessern test
kapazitäten behandlungskapazitäten und
kapazitäten im öffentlichen
gesundheitswesen
wir müssen infektionen die jetzt
auftreten früh erkennen
das schaffen wir weil wir zurzeit wenige
infektion im land haben die chance ist
größer geworden und wenn die auftreten
müssen sie schnell erkannt werden es
musste schnell kontakt nachverfolgung
durchgeführt werden dafür haben wir auch
gesorgt dass dort kapazitäten wachsen
und dann wollen wir hoffen und das ist
das ziel das wir gemeinsam in diesem
neuen alltag indem wir weiterhin abstand
halten
dass wir diese infektionen schnell
erkennen und ausbrüche schnell
unterbinden können
auch noch mal eine frage zu den
sogenannten alleingängen vom rk ii war
in der vergangenheit öfter zu hören dass
man regional unterschiedlich auf die
jeweilige lage reagieren soll daher
meine frage sind die häufig kritisierten
alleingänge eigentlich aus rk ii sich
das richtige mittel
naja jeder weiß dass es regionale
unterschiede gibt
wir alle denke ich wünschen uns gerade
wenn es um eine kommunikation zur
bevölkerung geht natürlich einen
gemeinsamen plan und dieser gemeinsame
planen wurde bislang auch sehr
erfolgreich durchgesetzt und das ist
natürlich immer lokal gegebenheiten gibt
wo man innerhalb dieses planes ein wenig
variiert ich danke das ist völlig normal
und selbstverständlich ich möchte noch
mal sagen die kapazitäten die die
regionalen gegebenheiten sind einfach
unterschiedlich
und dem muss man auch immer weiter
rechnung tragen das ist aus meiner sicht
auch eben eine der großen stärken eines
föderalen systems vor ort die menschen
müssen ja die infektion beherrschen sie
wissen sicher am besten wie sie das tun
können sie müssen halt sensibel genug
sein wenn sie dann wieder mehrere
ausbrüche haben oder größere ausbrüche
haben dass sie schnell genug reagieren
und dann auch zb um unterstützung bitten
wir haben wir schon sehr sehr viele
unterstützungsbesuch erhalten im rahmen
von ausbrüchen sei es dass wir mit teams
vor ort fahren und dann die ausbrüche
unterstützen in der regel beschränken
wir uns aber aus kapazitätsgründen hier
auf telefonische beratung und das ist
ein feedback ein integrativer
mechanismus wo wir eigentlich
kontinuierlich und verbessere die taz
herzfeld sie haben eben noch betont wie
wichtig ist dass man schnell kontakt
nachverfolgung machen kann jetzt um eine
neue welle zu verhindern dazu war ja
eigentlich auch die app gedacht genau
dabei helfen sollte und nie eigentlich
längst da sein sollte lieber mal die
hoffnung dass es die anfang mai geben
würde nun gibt es die man noch nicht da
wollte ich zum einen mal hören können
sie uns noch mal sagen aus ihrer sicht
woran das eigentlich dass das die jetzt
immer noch nicht gibt und zum anderen
kommt die dann geht es möglicherweise
sogar schon zu spät wenn sie kommt weil
wenn die zahlen relativ gering sind ja
vielleicht bei den leuten ist auch gar
nicht mehr die notwendigkeit gesehen
wird die zu installieren hat man da also
den zeitpunkt schon verpassten die efrag
sein könnte also diese app ist
kompliziert zu programmieren sie
technisch anspruchsvoll
das konzept ist anspruchsvoll sie haben
ja auch verfolgt dass es in einem
konsortium von willigen wo wirklich sehr
viele menschen unentgeltlich nebenbei
mit sehr viel enthusiasmus eine tolle
idee verfolgt haben das hat dann dazu
geführt dass es zwei lager gab die sich
entwickelt haben das hat den prozess
sicher verlangsamt aber das hat mit der
werft weiter getrieben
mit aller verve jetzt ist t-systems ein
wichtiger player und sap wir sind ja
auch involviert in die entwicklung
dieser app wobei wir uns natürlich rein
auf das epidemiologische dieser
beschränken und natürlich ist der
datenschutz ganz wichtig und natürlich
ist auch die it sicherheit ganz wichtig
und auch die privacy policy also die die
menschen die diese app freiwillig
runterladen
wir müssen natürlich auch davon
überzeugt sein dass tun wir das was wir
können das dass diese ganzen ansprüchen
genügt genüge getragen wird und das ist
in deutschland eben anspruchsvoll wir
sind ein land das sehr viel wert auf
diese aspekte legen und das dauert
einfach wann das sein wird weiß ich
nicht
war es aber wichtig ist und das möchte
ich auch noch mal betonen
das ist eine pandemie und bei einer
pandemie wird dieses virus so lange im
krankheits bereich sein und krankheit
eine 5 bis 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung infiziert sind
darum wissen wir dass es mit großer
sicherheit eine zweite welle gibt die
die mehrheit der wissenschaftler ist
sich dessen sicher und man geht auch
davon aus dass eine dritte wellige das
heißt also diese app kommt nicht zu spät
weil wir nämlich in dieser zweiten welle
wenn sie denn kommt genau alle diese
tools brauchen ja das ist sehr sehr
wichtig zu verstehen
je mehr werkzeuge wir haben und die app
ist ja auch nur ein werkzeug sie ist ja
nicht das alleinige werkzeug sondern
nach wie vor wenn ja kontakte nach
verfolgt mit den konventionellen
methoden auch da haben wir die
gesundheitsämter jahr unterstützt sowohl
oder werden unterstützt sowohl
finanziell als auch mit anderen
digitalen möglichkeiten die melde
software die vom robert-koch-institut
etwa programmiert wird wird verbessert
die meldewege die elektronischen werden
beschleunigt erleichtert die meldewege
zum beispiel labortest ist erleichtert
worden
das ist ja ein ganzer strauß von
maßnahmen den die menschen natürlich
nicht immer im einzelnen spielklassen
ganzer strauß von maßnahmen inklusive
verschiedener änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz die die
reaktivität deutlich erhöht haben also
das heißt ich gehe davon aus dass wir
diese app noch brauchen werden in
unserem land wenn sie sagen sie sind
auch im prozess involviert können so
zumindest mal so einer größenordnung
geben was sie glauben weil es die jetzt
tatsächlich geben wird es ist nicht
ideal einzuschätzen darum möchte ich
mich wirklich nicht zu äußern sie können
nur
versichert sein dass die arbeit leider
sieben tage die woche ohne rücksicht auf
irgendwelche feiertage von einem kern
von mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern nach
wie vor betrieben wird am besten wissen
und gewissen
wir gehen zum handelsblatt die rolle der
kinder entwicklung der pandemie
schildern und das auch differenzieren
nach den jüngeren und nach größeren also
die isländer und die schweden ging er
glaube ich davon aus dass die keine
große rolle spielen kann man dem folgen
ja einfache frage schwieriger antwort
also tatsächlich ist es so dass ich
diese frage immer noch nicht sehr klar
eindeutig beantworten kann ich selber
hatte auch vor kurzem es wieder
gespräche mit epidemiologen aus den
entsprechenden ländern
es ist so dass es einige studien gibt
diese studien haben aber alle eine reihe
von design schwächen weil sie schnell
gemacht wurden und beobachtungsstudien
sind die teilweise auch erst später
gemacht wurden es wurden ja vor der
schulschließung wurden ja nicht
systematisch untersuchen gemacht sondern
hinterher beobachtet man ein wenig in
schweden ist es so dass sie wissen dass
die schweden auf der anderen seite
natürlich sehr viele todesfälle haben
und dass dort also diese
infektionskrankheit insgesamt schon
große spuren hinterlässt aber in
schweden ist es so dass die schule
aufgehalten wurden
und das spricht dafür dass kinder nicht
so eine große rolle spielen für den
infektionsverlauf das ist aber kein
finaler beweis
es ist bekannt dass kinder das virus das
kinder infiziert werden können
es ist bekannt dass kinder insgesamt
nicht so viel
als last tragen also die krankheiten bei
kindern sind verglichen mit älteren
altersgruppen geringer es ist aber
bekannt dass kinder natürlich auch das
virus ausscheiden und andere anstecken
können es gibt bislang keinen hinweis
darauf dass die kinder ähnlich wie wir
das bei influenza kennen das spiel
kindern eine sehr große rolle
dass das beim corona virus so wäre ist
hier so aus die daten die bisher
vorliegen das ist nicht so eine große
rolle für die weiterverbreitung spielt
das ist der eine aspekt von seiten des
virus den wir im kopf haben müssen
der andere aspekt ist aber der natürlich
ist das sozialverhalten der kinder wenn
wir eben immer sagen denn der neue
alltag ist abstand halten ist natürlich
klar dass das für kinder deutlich
schwieriger ist und insofern können sie
natürlich eine rolle bei der
weiterverbreitung spielen aber bislang
gibt es keine hinweise darauf dass
kinder eine besonders große rolle bei
der weiterverarbeitung von cobit 19
spielen ist aber noch nicht abschließend
geklärt und zu ihrer altersfrage da
würde ich genau das auch beantworten
jetzt unabhängig von der virus
ausscheidung infektiosität gehen wir
natürlich davon aus dass ältere kinder
ich eben disziplinierte an diese hygiene
regeln halten können und dann wurde
deren potenzial andere anzustecken
natürlich geringer sein
vielen dank
der ärztliche nachrichtendienst vom
mißlbeck ja hallo guten morgen hören sie
mich wunderbar ich hab noch eine frage
zu den unterschiedlichen tempo der
lockerungen in der politik wächst ja der
wunsch danach föderale unterschiede beim
tempo der lockerungen durch einheitliche
kriterien zusammenzubinden wurden sie
denn bereits angefragt nach
entsprechenden vorgaben und haben sie
der event in china schon in der
entwicklung nach dem motto wenn er unter
0,5 sinkt und die intensiv kapazitäten
und die kapazitäten der gesundheitsämter
so und so sind dann ist dieses und jenes
möglich ja das ist ein wunsch den sicher
viele haben aber ich möchte das noch mal
betonen es gibt regionale unterschiede
ich nehme ein beispiel nehmen wir mal
zum beispiel die die inzidenz pro
hunderttausend oder so es gibt regionen
da kann die inzidenz steigen dann haben
wir zb
ein ausbruch in einem sagen wir jetzt
mal in einer einrichtung einem
altersheim oder ein pflegeheim
dann steigt die inzidenz vielleicht sehr
schnell über einen gewissen grenzwert
aber da das ein lokales geschehen ist
obwohl die zahl vielleicht hoch ist
eines bestimmten incidents wird kann man
diesen ausbruch dann sehr einfach
vielleicht ein grenzen weil man die
quelle weiss das infektionsgeschehen ist
überschaubar und dann spielt hier die
absolute instanz vielleicht gar nicht
die entscheidende rolle für die
bewertung der schwere hat man aber zum
beispiel in einem landkreis auch die
gleiche intelligenz zahl hat aber ein
verschiedene ausbrüche weiß die quellen
gar nicht genau was ist ja immer noch
gibt dass sie die so genannten index
patienten nicht kennen oder so dann ist
dieser ausbruch zum beispiel schwerer zu
bekämpfen
und dann braucht dieses land oder dieser
region eine größere unterstützung
mehraufwand diesen ausbruch zu bekämpfen
kommt genauso darauf an wie fällt welche
menschen infiziert sind ja sind es
vorwiegend ältere dann ist wiederum die
krankheitslast höher sind als jüngere
kinder wie wir gerade sagten die in der
regel nicht schwer erkranken ist es auch
wiederum von geringere größe es heißt
klare grenzwerte zu benennen halte ich
für schwer vermittelbar weil vor ort die
situation immer erkannt werden muss von
denjenigen die diesen ausspruch
bekämpfen da würde man sich in einer
falschen sicherheit wägen und würde
vielleicht ein trigger ziehen der dann
angemessen ist oder vielleicht ist er
sogar zu spät weil eine bestimmte
situation vor ort falls es wirklich
wichtig dass die verantwortlichen vor
ort das realistisch einschätzen und auch
die erhalten ja immer mehr informationen
im rahmen der des monitoring dass sie
immer fein teilige auch reagieren und
einschätzen können
ja das ist ja eine aufgabe des
robert-koch-instituts kriterien zu
empfehlen und das sind die kriterien die
ich eben genannt habe aus diesen drei
bereichen transmission schwere der
krankheit und kapazität des
gesundheitswesens und des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes
wir gehen zu haben können sie noch sagen
welche redaktionen sie vertreten
ja natürlich erst mal den schönen guten
morgen radio metropole
nachrichtenredaktion projekts mein name
ich hoffe sie hören mich ja wunderbar
guten morgen herr professor wieder guten
morgen an alle teilnehmer der wähler
sollte es zu einer zweiten welle der
pandemie kommen
inwiefern wären wir vorbereitet müssten
erneut härtere maßnahmen ergriffen
werden zumal jetzt über lockerungen und
normalität gesprochen wird
also die vorbereitung ist definitiv gut
wir haben ja in den letzten monaten viel
dafür getan ich habe einige der
maßnahmen erläutert wir haben ja auch
eine reihe von empfehlungen erstellt die
umgesetzt werden der umgang mit der
krankheit ist besser geworden wir werden
natürlich auch und das möchte ich auch
noch mal sagen an der stelle
wir werden auch da sind viele
optimistisch bessere therapeutika haben
die chancen der therapie werden besser
die menschen die ärzte wissen inzwischen
besser wie sie mit patienten umgehen
müssen und das heißt also die
vorbereitung ist definitiv besser
definitiv besser und klar ist je nachdem
wie stark diese welle wird wird es
natürlich dazu kommen dass man wieder
bestimmte maßnahmen durch schön muss
wenn man die welle bremsen möchte ich
wüsste nicht wie das anders handelbar
ist
und das wird man dann sehen wir wissen
inzwischen wie die maßnahmen
funktionieren und wirken und da wird es
sicher auch gezielte maßnahmen geben
müssen ja herr professor wenn sie
gestatten eine kurze frage hätte ich
noch kann man sagen dass wenn es in
ferner zeit zu keinen impfstoff kommen
sollte dass man sich jetzt an diese neue
normalität praktisch gewöhnen muss wie
sehen sie das
naja also sie sagen es ja schon neue
normalität also neue normalität neue
alltag also dieses abstand halten diese
hygieneregeln
ich denke das wird uns noch einige
monate sicher begleiten das ist eine
wichtige lehre da müssen wir uns daran
gewöhnen und das ist auch wichtig dass
wir das tun damit wir unser leben
da zurückkriegen so wie wir das alle uns
wünschen und ich denke diese regeln
einzuhalten ist machbar und wir sollten
auch nicht nachlassen
diese disziplin zu wahren denn diesen
erfolg den wir uns wirklich hart
erarbeitet durch kluge entscheidungen
und durch eine disziplinierte mit
menschen die diese entscheidung getragen
und umgesetzt haben und das kann auch
meiner ansicht nach gerade das
abstandhalten ist wirklich ein teil
einer neuen normalität ja bis das vorbei
ist
wir gehen zu planet interview hervor
hallo ja hören sie mich guten morgen und
ich habe zur influenza bzw bekämpfung
der influenza haben ihrem zwei kurze
fragen und wenn möglich eine nachfrage
wenn ich die da noch stellen darf es
wurde ja hier immer wieder verwiesen
auch die existierende grippe impfungen
können sie nochmal sagen welchen schutz
die eigentlich bietet weil ich habe auch
von medizinern gehört dass der schutz in
schlechten jahren sagen wenn man nur bei
zehn prozent liegt und dann noch die
andere frage in welchem bereich ungefähr
liegt das durchschnittsalter der
influenza verstorbenen und wie gesagt
wenn eine nachfrage noch möglich ist
also influenza impfstoffe ist es ist
eine schwierige frage
influenzaviren sind sehr sehr stark
veränderbar dass das erbgut von
influenza-viren ändert sich relativ
schnell mit zwei methoden das eine sind
die klassischen mutationen also wo
einzelne gene einzel basenpaare quasi
mutieren und das andere ist das ganze
gehen gehen segmente ausgetauscht werden
teilweise das ist das macht dieses
influenza virus so schwierig
vorhersehbar weil es so viele reserve
hat insbesondere in wildvögel in firmen
in wasservögeln und jeder influenza
impfstoff besteht aus mehreren
komponenten
insgesamt haben wir vier komponenten zur
zeit es gibt eine b linie da gibt es
zwei berlin in die sind beide inzwischen
in dem impfstoff drin in dem normalen
der jedes jahr wieder neu hergestellt
und wir haben zwei aus der sogenannten a
linie da haben wir auch zwei impfstoff
komponenten drin und diese komponenten
werden jedes jahr neu ausgewählt und es
wird immer vorher im märz des jahres
also im märz aber 2020 jetzt also ist
schon entschieden worden
mit welchem impfstoff wir im herbst 2020
geben stören und in der zwischenzeit
können sich die währung manchmal ändern
die effektivität der impfung ist sehr
davon abhängig welches virus denn nun
dominiert in der jeweiligen grippesaison
und es ist sehr stark davon abhängig
welche altersgruppe betroffen ist wenn
wir diese gerade diese h3 viren haben
die sind oft bei älteren personen machen
die schwere krankheit verläuft die h1
viren machen in der regel bei jüngeren
personen schwere krankheitsverläufe das
heißt es hängt immer davon ab
wenn sie sich anschauen die todeszahlen
bei grippe die wir ja auch immer erst
nachher errechnen über mit dieser exzess
mortalität und wer betroffen ist dann
haben sie natürlich 85 prozent der
diejenigen die im rahmen von diesen
grippewellen versterben sind auch
menschen über 65 also auch alte und
hochaltrigen menschen verstehen ohne
frage und ja nur eine kurze nachfrage
wir erleben jetzt ein großes repertoire
an an maßnahmen gegen kuwait 19 diese
heutigen maßnahmen sagen wir
exemplarisch absage von
großveranstaltungen kita
schulschließungen oder auch vielleicht
eine zukünftige app welche von diesen
maßnahmen würden sie gerne zukünftig für
die bekämpfung der grippe anwenden also
die sind natürlich auch effektiv gegen
die krippe aber da die grippe nun mal
deutlich geringere mortalität hat also
die die die anzahl der menschen die
schwer erkranken ist zum einen deutlich
größer bykow mit 19 zum anderen aber
nochmal das ist ein ganz entscheidender
unterschied gegen grippe gibt es
natürlich in jedem land der welt grund
immunität weil dieses grippevirus er
seit jahrzehnten immer wieder durch die
bevölkerung geht und da gibt es eben
eine grundimmunisierung
mit 19 nicht gegeben zur zeit als wir
haben vielleicht drei prozent oder in
dem bereich der der deutschen sind
bislang infiziert worden
solange wir diese grund immunität haben
kann man das eben nicht miteinander
vergleichen
wir haben eine impfung gegen die grippe
wir haben keine impfung gegen 11 uhr
wird 19 was ich mir wünschen würde wäre
dass endlich alle die menschen wohl die
stiko sie auffordert dass sie sich doch
mit der impfen lassen gegen die grippe
nämlich diese sogenannten risikogruppen
dass sie das einfach tun
dann hätten wir nämlich auch wenn die
grippe impfungen in der effektivität
schwankt würden wir eine menge leben
retten also das wäre mein wunsch und der
zweite wunsch ist der dass wir in
zukunft auch noch bessere influenza
impfstoffe haben denn diese influenza
impfstoffe wie sie das sagen schwanken
in der effektivität ein paar influenza
impfstoff der alle update wenn natürlich
großartig und es ist eben genau so
wichtig und das wird uns sicher auch
helfen bei der nächsten grippewelle wenn
die menschen auch diese abstandsgebot
erhalten und die hygieneregeln einhalten
hände waschen dann werden wir natürlich
auch effekte auf die grippeimpfung haben
und das sind maßnahmen die sind wirklich
angebracht werden mal schauen ob die
nächste grippewelle auch also die
grippewelle soll darunter leiden unter
den maßen aber die menschen in
deutschland sollen davon profitieren von
diesen maßnahmen wir gehen zum
deutschlandfunk kultur herr meier
war ein versuch wert der provinz gleich
nochmal beginnt zu haben fällt wisch
freier journalist nicht ausreichend klar
wo im moment die menschen sich und
beziehen die sich derzeit infizieren
heute fragen ob das mit erfasst wird
also wird es mit gemeldet so weit
bekannt ist ob die infektion innerhalb
der familien hatten haushalt der arbeit
oder ähnliches passiert und wenn ich
sollte es nicht auch mit gemeldeten
erfasst werden ja ja die frage war eben
schon mal gestellt worden ja natürlich
hätten wir diese information gerne
wir wissen momentan ist nicht genau und
wir hätten die info gerne wenn man
natürlich auch dann gezielt in diesen
bereichen noch intervenieren kann
informationen geben kann darauf
hinweisen kann
wir wissen dass rund ein drittel der
aktuellen fälle aus solchen
einrichtungen kommen also
pflegeeinrichtungen heime krankenhäuser
aber viel mehr informationen darüber die
anderen fälle haben wir leider nicht das
hängt damit zusammen dass immer noch die
gesundheitsämter sehr stark damit
befasst sind die fälle zu bearbeiten und
die publikationen dazu die auswärtigen
die wissenschaftlichen auswertung die
wir ja auch mit gesundheitsämtern
zusammen leisten
die hängen leider noch hinterher auf
einfach aufgrund der arbeitsüberlastung
das mit gemeldet werden bei der meldung
oder sollte werden das ist ja der kann
mit gemeldet werden das ist das ist klar
also es ist nicht verboten und natürlich
würden wir auch dass es mit gemeldet
wird aber das gelingt eben nicht immer
wir probieren es nochmal deutschland von
kultur herr meier können sie nicht jetzt
schon einstellung
ich habe noch eine verständnis frage zu
dem antikörper test nur kurz
angesprochen wenn sie sagen die
spezifität liegt über 99 prozent bezieht
sich das dann ausschließlich aussah
scott zwei antikörper also ist der test
dann nur in allen prozent falsch positiv
verstehe ich das richtig
und dazu auch ist dieser test zugelassen
oder wie die bisherigen auch ist der vom
hersteller zertifiziert ja das ist eine
gute frage also meines wissen dieses
zugelassen
tschuldigung zertifiziert
ich glaube dass wir in deutschland noch
bis zum 22 und bis zum jahr 2022 noch
auf diese art zertifizieren
meines wissens ist der test eben
zertifiziert und nicht zugelassen
wenn ich das richtig verschlossen war
ich denke schon
und und die aber das was sie sagen es
richtig der test ist eben evaluiert
worden mit mit einigen tausend patienten
wären meines wissens und darauf beziehen
sich die dazu spezifität und
sensitivität und das ist nach den daten
sehr spezifisch für das saas corona 2
virus wie das mit mit negativen also
wenn man das in einem bestimmten setting
testen würde wenn man also sehr sehr
wenig prävalenz von diesen viren in der
population hätte wie das dann aussehen
das kann ich ihnen nicht genau sagen die
sind auf jeden fall mit klar definierten
positiven klar definierten negativserien
überprüft worden das sind angaben des
herstellers herzlich lange wir gehen zu
radio münchen die frau schmidt guten
morgen herr professor wieder in der zib
am vergangenen freitag hat herr drosten
die akquise mit der spanischen grippe
vergleichen
das ist insofern interessant weil es ja
auch im internen kommunikationsstrategie
papier des innenministeriums die
aufforderung gibt zur verdeutlichung des
worst case historisch zu argumentieren
in genau mit der spanischen grippe im
vergleich hat herr droste nicht weiter
durch beispiele gestützt
man schätzt ja dass es damals 27 50
millionen todesopfer gab zeichnet sich
bis heute denn nicht er ab dass dies auf
zwei krise mindestzahlen mäßig er mit
der schweinegrippe zu vergleichen sein
wird und mich interessieren die faktoren
die einen vergleich mit der spanischen
grippe rechtfertigen würden also von der
sogenannten schweinegrippe
da wissen wir dass die weltweit so rund
180.000 todesopfer gefordert hat das ist
sehr wenig und die sind in erster linie
auch
durch eine schätzung errechnet worden
also nicht erfasste fälle
wir haben ja jetzt schon erfasste fälle
also offiziell gemeldet und da sind
natürlich dunkelziffern dabei dass das
muss man ja mal ganz deutlich sagen
insbesondere in vielen ländern außerhalb
europas das ist sicher nicht
vergleichbar also diese cupid 19 hat
eine deutlich größere schwerer als die
schweinegrippe
was man aber auch nicht vergessen darf
das möchte ich auch noch mal betonen die
spanische grippe sie haben die zahlen
korrekt genannt die berechnet wenn das
sind ja auch berechnete geschätzte zahl
sind ja nicht offiziell gemeldete zahl
die spanische grippe ist natürlich zu
einem zeitpunkt aufgetreten als die
medizin nicht annähernd so gut war wie
heute ja die beratungsmöglichkeiten gab
es ja früher gar nicht
die intensiv medizin die die war ja gar
nicht existent das heißt also wenn wir
eine spanische grippe heute quasi dieses
selbe virus heute hätten mit der mit mit
der virulenz mit der kann man einfach
der wird auch heute die spanische grippe
deutlich besser abfangen
der punkt ist der dass wir drei dinge
getan haben also in den letzten
jahrzehnten als natürlich die medizin
verbessert wir haben intensiv medizin
wir haben medikamente 1918 gab keine
medikamente gegen das virus wir haben
natürlich eine deutlich modernere
bessere medizin
wir haben viel mehr möglichkeiten jetzt
hygiene maßnahmen durchzusetzen
kampagnen zu machen und leuten den
umgang damit beizubringen wir machen das
ja schon seit vielen jahren im rahmen
der grippewelle immer wieder die leute
auf die hygieneregeln hin zu wollen und
natürlich haben wir hier massive
maßnahmen gefahren
die viele als shutdown oder lockdown
betrachten das sind die gründe warum wir
überhaupt nur so wenig tote haben ja
deshalb können sie das nicht vergleichen
denn zum damaligen zeitpunkt ist diese
krippe um die welt gegangen und mehr
oder weniger ungeschützt über die
population hinweggegangen damals gab es
ja eine so schnelle verbreitung von
nachrichten von informationen gar nicht
wenn sie anschauen wie viele länder
inzwischen diese maßnahmen gefahren
haben um sich cupid entgegenzustemmen
das
ein ganz anderes eine ganz andere
zeitachse insofern kann man das sehr
schwer vergleichen
man kann es insofern vergleichen also
ist eben ein virus ist das ein
pandemischer potenzial hat keine
immunität in der bevölkerung und zu
vielen schweren krankheitsverläufen
führt und zu vielen todesfälle wir gehen
zur ad hoc times die frau sich ja schon
morgen herr professor wieder
es gab am wochenende massentest im
landkreis greiz und den fünf stationären
pflegeeinrichtungen wurden bis zu 1000
bewohner pflegekräfte und patienten und
personal einer fachklinik getestet meine
frage dazu wie wirken sich diese tests
auf die statistiken kreis greiz aus und
wird es versprechen sie sich von diesen
tests und kinder sind ja bislang in
diesen erkrankungen statistiken in den
fallzahlen nicht so auffällig welche
gründe würden dafür sprechen bei
vorhandensein eines impfstoffs die
kinder impfen oder zwangs impfen zu
lassen also die erste frage ist ein gute
frage die geht eben darin wie man dann
nachher die zahlen aus vehrte und
vergleicht den zusammenhang stellt
nochmal auch zurück auf die heinsberg
studie hängt eben immer von der region
ab die werden natürlich dazu führen dass
war insgesamt viele tests haben und wir
werden insgesamt wahrscheinlich weniger
positive tests haben die werden die test
positiven radio drücken
aber diese untersuchungen sind eben sehr
wichtig weil man in so einem gebiet wo
gerade in ausbruchsgeschehen ist und das
ist den kreis ebenso dann recht schnell
auch patienten ermittelt die vielleicht
gar keine symptome haben also die
symptomatisch infiziert sind oder
präsent tomate und dort kann man dann
schneller die infect ketten brechen das
andere mit den kindern mehr verstehe ich
nicht ganz die frage bezüglich der
impfung also wenn impfstoffe da sind und
es werden ja viele impfstoffe entwickelt
dann wissen wir noch nicht genau welche
impfstoffe das sein werden es werden ja
wenn sie da sind wahrscheinlich mehrere
geben und dann wird es je nach impfstoff
verschiedene indikationen geben das muss
dann immer überprüft werden
in deutschland macht das ja die stiko
die wird anhand der herstellerangaben
also da müssen die klinische tests zur
wirksamkeit und zur untätigkeit
durchgeführt werden
und die wird anhand der daten und im
zusammenhang mit dem epidemiologischen
geschehen dass dann besteht bewerten
welche gruppen von menschen mit diesem
oder jenem stoff am besten zu impfen
sind ihr kommen zur letzten frage ein
teilnehmer der nur die telefonnummer
angegeben hat das auf rot der aufruf mit
der bitte auch nochmal namen und
redaktion zu sagen und das beim nächsten
mal noch direkt anzugeben
ja mach historisches mediengruppe rtl
ich habe nochmal nachfragen rolle der
kinder es hat ja letzte woche auf einer
auswertung um professor thorsten charité
team gegeben labordaten rachenabstriche
von kindern wo die viruslast relativ
hoch war wie bewerten sie diese studie
und was ist damit gesagt für die
diskussion und öffnung von schulen und
kitas
ja das ist eine wichtige studie die ist
aber nicht repräsentativ das sind eben
relativ wenige fälle
sie zeigen dass kinder eben auch das
virus ausscheiden und auch sie eben
offensichtlich auch hohe virus lasten
haben aber sie geben kann
hinweis darüber wie viel prozent der
kinder das sind ist ja keine
repräsentative studie ist eine wichtige
studie wieder ein baustein in der
diskussion aber wie es auch anfang sagte
es gibt eben noch nicht genug evidenz um
daraus gewicht große schlussfolgerung zu
ziehen ein weiterer baustein der der
belegt einfach dass kinder sowohl
infiziert sein können das so oft aber
nicht krank werden und dass er das virus
auch ausschalten können und auch andere
infizieren können die rolle von ihnen
damit in dem infektionsgeschehen kann
man daraus aber leider nicht ableiten
vielen dank dann sind wir beim ende wir
sehen uns diese woche ausnahmsweise noch
mal am donnerstag wieder weil freitag
der 8 mai in berlin feiertag ist wegen
75 jahre krieg seine also donnerstag 17
uhr bis dahin vielen dank wieder schon
[Applaus]
[Musik]